>>Teacher: The swine-flu
snake greeting.
Morning, Morning, Morning,
Morning, Morning.
>>Narrator: At Carrithers
Middle School, the day begins
with goofy games, which are often
followed by serious discussions.
>>Teacher: We've been
discussing bullying all week long.
>>Narrator: The 20 minutes spent
in this daily morning meeting
is a critical component
of Jefferson County,
Kentucky's, district-wide CARE
for Kids initiative, which
seeks to build positive,
caring learning communities.
>>Sheldon: There's a pretty complex
puzzle that we have to put together
to have a successful school,
but a foundational element
of that puzzle is the culture
and climate of that school,
and when students feel safe.
>>Teacher: Hello, sweet girl.
You have a good day, okay?
>>Sheldon: When they feel that
culture and climate supports that,
when they feel cared about not
only by the adults in the school...
>>Teacher: Got that?
>>Sheldon: ...but by other students
in the school, they
can do their best.
>>Teacher: Look at the name
and think of something nice
to say about that person.
>>Deirdre: Good morning, Storm.
>>Storm: Good morning, Deirdre.
>>Deirdre: I like your humor.
>>Sheldon: It isn't
touchy-feely stuff.
It's core social skills that
gives students the experience
and the knowledge to work
effectively with others.
>>Student: Thanks for
always being nice.
>>Paul: It's teaching kids
how to CARE for one another,
how to be a bigger person
and how to resolve conflicts.
>>When the cold wind blows, it
blows for whoever has on shoes.
>>When you give us activities or
we able to move, get all our noises
out before school and stuff, it
gives us more hype about learning.
>>Alicia: Less instructional
time is lost
because we're teaching the skills up
front, and so that when it is time
for academics, we're learning and
we're not stopping at various times
to address conflicts, and
it's teaching the students how
to have ownership and have voice.
>>Joanna: Tell Jasmine what
you think is special about her.
>>Student: I like when
you share with me.
>>Jasmine: Thank you.
Caroline?
>>Joanna: They're excited.
They want to be here.
I've had parents say, "My
daughter's sick today, but she cried,
because she really
wanted to come to school.
What are you all doing?"
>>Jasmine: Thanks for
filling my bucket.
>>Joanna: How did they fill
your bucket today, Jasmine?
>>Jasmine: Because they
was being nice to me.
>>Richard: Stay in line.
Don't run.
>>I like this program and I see
this program that's been implemented
and it works, because I was
here, and I seen it for myself.
>>See you tomorrow, okay, buddy?
>>At the end of the day, those
kids getting on those buses
with a smile on their face.
My job is done.
I can safely go home
and say, "You know what?
When they came this
morning they had smiles,
and when they left, they had smiles.
Our job is done, because I'm there."
>>Your mom's outside.
Your mom's right there, Madison.
>>Narrator: For more
information about what works
in public education,
go to edutopia.org.